now I'm reading you spent $ two [__]
million on a magic the Gathering one
ring card what is this $2 million card
you bought so it's a very special card
so it was printed in The Lord of the
Ring set for Magic the Gathering it was
one card one card supposedly Wizards of
the Coast please do not print another
copy of this card um so it's a one of
one and it was supposed to be like the
actual the ring one ring to rule them
all and then the darkness by them it's
almost like the Willy Wonka um golden
ticket so it's just like you keep
opening up candy you keep open up Candy
and then one guy will just find it and
it's like oh [__] and there was a
beautiful man from Canada who came to a
show and he said hey I have the graded
card and he worked at Costco he wanted
to raise some money for charity so I was
like you know what [__] it I'm going to
buy this $2 million piece of cardboard
is it going to turn turn out in the
future people are going to go wow post
Malone was a genius like the guy who
bought the first issue of the Superman
comic or this could be this stupidest
[__] thing ever right you don't know
at this point I told him I was like this
is the dumbest thing I've ever done in
my life but it brings me so much
happiness that I want to do it you have
business people right do you have to go
to them and say listen I need you to cut
a check for 2 million cuz I'm buying a
piece of cardboard you know is there
someone watching those explaining that
to my account
was the [__] craziest thing of all
time I was like look this is really cool
you guys don't I I think what needs to
happen is there needs to be an
accounting firm that just deals in dumb
[__] like uh like magic cards or and
magic cards are not dumb but it was a
dumb purchase but you have insurance on
the card yes sir yes sir yeah okay okay
and it's so cool and explain exping that
to them I was like hey you guys might
not understand it but I really love it
and I love this game and I'm very
passionate about this and we're going to
wire that $2 million over to this guy
wow it's cool because it changed his
life and it brought me so much joy and
it brought um the people I play with a
lot of joy as well so it was worth it
100% can you imagine the meeting that
those accountants had like after they
hang up with you they go there
[__] he's crazy what are we
going to do it's his money Deon
5 down to the bottom floors of the
[__] office what happens when you go
to like the dentist and you spent like
1.2 million on two diamond encrusted
teeth in your mouth that's a hard sell
too yeah is are those the same guys even
when you lost that $600,000 tooth a
couple of times like those are the guys
he got a almost lost it almost lost it
almost lost how you almost lose on a
chicken nugget and then once on bread
terrible cuz I eat like I'm 2 years old
so I feel like isn't that the ultimate
irony a $600,000 tooth was almost lost
on a chicken nugget like that's
beautiful it's like David and
Goliath dude you should write a song
about that [__] yeah I already did oh
you haven't heard it the $600,000 tooth
that was lost on a chicken nugget oh
yeah I did hear that one very good you
remember that one yeah very good